Ciao ragazzi bentornati ad una nuova
puntata di Cucina Buttata - Ma che è? (Enrico)
- Ma che succede? Chi è? Jasmin! Per favore... - Puoi non chiamare...  (E) - Per favore!
- Il tuo moroso, colui al quale le guance
si trasformano in laghée di porpora
quando si parla di te... Shhh - Andiamo ad origliare - Chissenefrega del Big Mac
"Hey ciao come va?"
- C'è del materiale scottante? (G)
- No no...Un po' di tempo fa abbiamo provato
a fare il Crispy Mc Bacon
poi abbiamo provato a fare i Chicken
McNuggets, tutte ricette che erano
solamente preludio a un unico panino che
meritava di essere fatto
- Io non sono d'accordo (E) - Io pure preferiso il Crispy      - Non va bene (E)
- Si ma funzionava per creare il pathos...
vendiamoci per un attimo
L'unico vero panino che esiste, il Big Mac, che comunque è meno buono del Crispy Mc Bacon
Ragazzi siete team Crispy o team Bic Mac? - L'hai detto in una modo tale che uno non poteva non dire... (E)
- Crispy. In realtà la cosa veramente difficile da imitare dei panini del Mcdonald's sono le salse, noi
però abbiamo un esercito di hacker che è
riuscito ad accedere a un blog che si
chiama foxvalleyfoodie.com, il cui link vi lascio pure
in descrizione, da effettivamente un'idea
di salsina da creare quando si va a fare il Big Mac. Ora io non lo mangio dai secoli il Big Mac, qualcuno di voi si
ricorda che sapore ha? - Io (G) - Tu? Quindi sarei molto critico? Perfetto - A parte gli scherzi abbiamo Gianmarco
che favorisce... - Tu sei? - Io sono a favore del Big (G)
- Quindi oggi se il nostro esperto! La
faccenda si fa ancora più intrigante. La
faccenda si fa ancora più intrigante. Per
fare la salsa del Big Mac avremo bisogno di
- Ah non abbiamo tutti gli ingredienti (E) - Per fare la salsa del Big Mac
non abbiamo tutti gli ingredienti, ma
serve di base maionese.... senape. Ragazzi
mi sono appena reso conto che questa è senape con miele - Nooo, serviva la mostarda (G)
- Vabbè ma è senape con miele - Cioè ragazzi, non si
può fare - No! E invece sì! Perché serve...mo vi spiego in che modo la senape con
miele ci salva e voi tutti zitti - Vabbè dai ci fidiamo di Chef Wilem
- Che c'entra la senape col miele con la mostarda?
- Questa cosa che si chiama sweet relish è
una salsa agrodolce fatta con i
cetriolini, noi quindi in questo momento
abbiamo una carenza di zucchero
all'interno della salsa ma che
prenderemo dal miele  -E la mostarda? (G) - E' senape - Ma che stai dicendo! (E)
- In pochi riescono a notare la differenza....cetriolini
vino bianco - Aceto (G) - Aceto di vino bianco,
aglio in polvere, cipolla in polvere
paprika. Manca questa salsa speciale
- La vuoi creare te questa salsa speciale? (G)
- Cetriolini con dello zucchero volevo mettere ma usiamo il miele, fidatevi di me
- Forse ha trovato la chiave di Volta in realtà (G)
- Grazie, uno che inizia a credere in me.
Mustard in realtà in italiano è senape
non mostarda. Silenzio! - Non ci credo (E) - Shh...ecco cosa voglio sentire...Teniamo i nostri viewers
con la tensione alta, non stanno vedendo
un programma di cucina, è un thriller
-  Mamma mia sti cetriolini ragazzi so buonissimi! (E) - Me ne fai assaggiare uno? (G)
- Ma ragazzi siamo ancora a guardare...
sono passati venti minuti dall'inizio di
questa cosa - Vabbè i thriller sono sempre un po'...
- Lenti all'inizio dici?...Abbiamo bisogno di una
tazza...ragazzi questi comprateveli
Lasciamo i link sotto, questi so vitali,
vitali per fare le mie ricette. Una tazza
di maionese, me coglioni! ... E' la mia salsa preferita - La più buona sai qual'è? (E)
- Maionese e barbeque insieme, ma per me è
buono contaminato, inzuppi su maionese e
poi inzuppi su barbeque e mangio. Tu sei uno che odia vero?
Quando la contaminazione? - O mischi o... (E)  - Mangi divisi - Si (E) - Siete team noi
o team stupido? Fatemelo sapere qua sotto. Un cucchiaio e mezzo di mostarda
Ricordiamoci che dentro questa mostarda
c'è anche del miele, poi ci aggiungiamo
spezzatini i cetriolini - "Zetrioli"! (E) - "I dzetrola, i dzetrola". Poi qua sotto in descrizione
vi mettiamo pure, se non usate le tazze,
come fare con i millilitri , i grammi e compagnia
bella, comunque un cucchiaio e mezzo. Son comodi, io continuo a dirlo che son comodi
"Sono comoti". Mezzo cucchiaino di paprika,
un quarto di polvere d'aglio...mi! Questo
qui mi ha ammazzato e un quarto, a no questo
qui è aglio, quell'altra cipolla. Dobbiamo
creare questa salsina...noo Enrico, col pestello? Ma
che è il Nome della Rosa che stiamo
facendo? Ah questa non l'abbiamo messa? Vabbè sta un po' andando così. Chiedo
scusa sono un po confuso ma qua sotto vi
mettiamo tutte quante le cose che dovete
infilare qua dentro. Un cucchiaio e mezzo,
quindi un quarto di tazza - Ti vedo spaesato Guglielmo (E)
- No ma come è tutto sotto controllo. Io non lo
mangio dai secoli - Non lo mangi dai secoli?
Ora mi faccio guidare...dalla folgorazione della cucina
Sto seguendo una voce nella mia testa
che sta parlando e mi sta facendo fare
questa salsa un pochino, capito? Cioè è come
se la stessi creando io la salsa
Questa qui gli butto, ho uno sguardo deciso. Il trita
patate, ti piace come idea? - Non credo che sia una... (E)
- E' un'idea pessima
E' buona comunque - E'
buonissima come salsa. Vieni ad
assaggiarlo - Forse un po' più di cetriolo - Allora inizialmente c'è, poi si perde, poi
di nuovo torna - Ma che c**** è un bambino? Guarda che ci sta perché ha quel retrogusto...  - E' giusto!
E' giusto! In frigo, ciao. Passiamo al panino - Io sono fiducioso (E) - Ah, mo. E' tipico del team stupidi
E' arrivato il momento di fare gli
hamburger. Si, credo che utilizzerò il più largo per
fare l'hamburger. Prendo il macinato. Facendomi i
conti per poter mangiare tutti noi, sono un 120 grammi di hamburger. Facciamo 100 ragazzi - Nooo (E)
- Secondo me è perfetto ragazzi. Perfetto,
a tra poco. Alla fine ho messo 120 grammi
Iniziamo a mettere i due hamburger... - Da
120 grammi (E) - Da 120 grammi
No no no! Dopo si sala! A fine cottura (E) - Sennò butta via tutti i liquidi (G) - E diventa una scarpa (E)
Il pane lo riscalderemo al forno. Dal momento che il Big Mac ha due strati e questi sono abbastanza
piatti, dovremo usare un'antica tecnica
di hokuto che adesso vi mostrerò
Prendiamo un panino e lo tagliamo a metà.
A questo punto ne prendiamo un altro e
togliamo la parte sotto e quella subito
sopra - Troppo spesso (E)
- Tu mi hai rotto il co... - Cioè! (E)
- E adesso anche con gli altri
Abbiamo fatto comunque un panino con
gli avanzi per evitare di buttare la
roba. E' arrivato il momento di preparare
gli ultimi ingredienti che serviranno
per l'assemblaggio finale. Cipolla per me è il nuovo profumo di dior. "Cipudda"
- Che va messa alla base vero? (G) - Delle ascelle
Intanto abbiamo tirato fuori i panini
dal forno in modo da tostarli
leggermente. Ricapitoliamo, qui abbiamo
cipolla, insalata, cetrioli, la salsa, il
pane. A questo punto manca la carne,
riscalderemo tre fette e metteremo
a sciogliere il cheddar sopra. Abbiamo
scoperto che il formaggio sta solamente
nel piano inferiore - E sotto è sotto all'hamburger (G) - Sotto all'hamburger, è l'amante che si nasconde
sotto al letto. E' vero non ho mai fatto vedere gli
ingredienti dell'hamburger - Per fare... (E) - ♬L'albero ci vuole il seme ♬
Mettiamo sopra il cheddar. E' arrivato il
momento quindi di assemblare. Primo
strato. Salsa, cipolla tritata - L'insalata , e po ci va il formaggio con sopra l'hamburger (G) - Quindi noi
prendiamo il panino e lo rigiriamo. AAAAAARG
Tramezzo del panino - Di nuovo salsa (G) - Di nuovo la cipolla - Ora abbiamo un po' di cetriolini (G) - La carne
E si chiude il panino (G) - Wow!
Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine della
nostra ricetta, è perfetto! Vi va di raggiungermi ? Solo che non
abbiamo fazzoletti...Bravo! Mamma mia!
3 2 1 via - Alla vostra
Sai io pure che cosa faccio? Allora devo dire... - Sei un po' un maiale - ♬ Parlami d'amore Mariù ♬ - La salsa del
Big Mac è più decisa, comunque è na bomba - A sapore non è il Big Mac - No fingi, che sia Big Mac
Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video. Noi non siamo più capaci di intendere e
di volere. Io in questo momento non voglio parlare
voglio solamente masticare. Come
sempre taggatemi su Instagram, fatemi
sapere se riproverete a fare questa
ricetta, io sono contento e mi diverto un sacco
quando vedo i vostri esperimenti. Se vi è
piaciuto questo video iscrivetevi al
canale, attivate la campanella delle
notifiche per non perdere le prossime
uscite ma soprattutto ci vediamo
domenica prossima alle 12 con un altro
episodio di Cucina Buttata. Ciao
Tu hai fatto ciao? Quello magnava e
basta ve? Magnava e basta - Della squadra stupidi - Del team noi  -Fateci soprattutto saper Big Mac o
Crispy - Capito? Il team noi non saluta - Che
schifo! - Il team stubito sub subito
"Il team sblubidum, il team sbubidum"
Grazie Enrico. Ciao
3 2 1 Ciao
Ragazzi, ci siamo appena resi conto di
una cosa, e secondo me un sacco di
persone se ne sono già rese conto. Non
abbiamo messo il grembiule, abbiamo fatto
una ricetta dimenticandoci dall'inizio
alla fine il grembiule - C'è da dire che
l'abbiamo fatto in rispetto di Dio (E)
- Nessuno mette Cristo in un angolo